[Applaus]
[Musik]
am 15 september 2021 verkündeten die
staats und regierungschef der
vereinigten staaten des vereinigten
königreichs und australiens ein
historisches abkommen vielleicht handelt
es sich um einen ersten schritt um den
lauf der weltgeschichte drastisch zu
verändern völlig überraschend und ohne
vorwarnung präsentierten die anführer
der drei englischsprachige nationen opus
das allerneuste militärbündnis auf
diesen planeten im rahmen des abkommens
wird australien seine marine durch die
integration neuer atom u boote zu einer
der stärksten der welt machen außerdem
das ist tomahawk-raketen erwerben und
sich massiv an der entwicklung von
überschall waffen quantentechnologie und
künstliche intelligenz beteiligen mit
autos erfährt die militärische
landschaft im indopazifik eine
revolution china nordkorea und
frankreich haben schon mal ihre
kategorische ablehnung begründet moment
mal china ist klar nordkorea auch aber
frankreich wieso ist gerade frankreich
dagegen keine angst wir werden diese
rätselhafte frage schon rechtzeitig
aufklären
wenden wir uns jedoch zunächst den
hauptakteuren zu unterdessen hat us
präsident obama nämlich die beziehungen
zwischen den usa und der volksrepublik
china den wettbewerb des jahrhunderts
bezeichnet
[Musik]
und andere autokraten dass die
demokratie im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert nichts mit autokratien
konkurrieren kann weil es zu lange
dauert einen konsens zu finden wir
stehen im wettbewerb mit china und
anderen ländern um das einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert zu gewinnen da stehen an
einem großen wendepunkt der geschichte
joe biden und das ist nicht nur die
meinung des präsidenten nur weniger in
washington haben zweifel dass diese
tatsache angeht der indopazifik ist die
mit abstand wichtigste region für die
zukunft die usa wir könnten viel reden
über die ukraine die türkei russland
venezuela oder gar mexiko aber die
wahrheit ist nunmal dass das
entscheidende spiel für die usa eben auf
diesen ganz speziellen schauplatz
stattfinden wird hier werden die karten
verteilen und hier werden die sieger
gekürt wenn es hart auf hart kommt und
genau darauf konzentrieren die usa den
großteil ihrer anstrengungen anfang märz
2021 bat der chef des pazifik kommandos
engel stelle davids um den kongress um
fast 30 milliarden dollar zusätzlich um
die militärischen ressourcen der usa in
der region zu stärken
wir reden über neue hochfrequenz
radarsysteme älteren für den austausch
von informationen
nachschub depots und neue angels
raketenabwehrsysteme auf der insel guam
und das ist noch nicht alles die us
streitkräfte wollen auch eine neue
stützpunkt in mikronesien bauen ihre
präsenz in guam verstärken und zusammen
mit australien einen gemeinsamen
stützpunkt in papua neuguinea einrichten
aber es geht nicht nur um neue
militärische ausrüstung lassen gar nicht
es geht auch um eine ganz neue politik
die usa ermutigen jahr waren zb
hyperschall waffen zu entwickeln und
seine raketen streitmacht zu ostern
außerdem haben sie im militärabkommen
mit den philippinen erneuert und ein und
2,6 milliarden dollar rettungspaket
zugestimmt dass die der inselrepublik
verkaufen werden darüber hinaus
kündigten die usa im mai sogar die
aufhebung aller beschränkungen an die
südkorea dazu verpflichten die
reichweite und nutzlast seiner im inland
produzierten raketen zu begrenzen die
idee dahinter ist dass die asiatischen
partner ihre militärischen kapazitäten
auf einen ganz neuen level hieven können
und washington dadurch die allianzen mit
ihren gleichzeitig stärken wird
[Musik]
darum wurden in den letzten jahren neue
militärabkommen mit ländern wie vietnam
indien und thailand mit aller höchster
priorität vorangetrieben und
gleichzeitig bündnisse und institutionen
wie die gurt oder die fünf ice
intensiviert alles themen über die wir
bereits schon auf visual politik
gesprochen haben es gibt sogar
spekulationen dass washington darüber
nachdenkt südkorea in die 51 aufzunehmen
jene geheimdienst allianz die es in
australien großbritannien kanada und
neuseeland zur größten spionage macht
des planeten gemacht hat
unsere abschreckungs haltung im
indopazifik muss die fähigkeit die
kapazität und den willen demonstrieren
peking unmissverständlich davon zu
überzeugen dass die kosten für die
erreichung ihrer ziele durch den einsatz
militärischer gewalt einfach zu hoch
sind und meral philip davies im chef des
innovativen kommandos das alles klingt
schon beeindruckend aber alles in allem
ist er vielleicht mit abstand wichtigste
schritt august
[Musik]
dieser trilaterale militär die liebe zur
folge haben dass australien zu einem
militärmacht mit einer der stärksten
apropos flotten der welt heranwächst
außerdem wird es mit einem gewaltigen
arsenal an tomahawk raketen ausgerüstet
die übrigens von den atom u boote selbst
starten können und das alles während die
enge zusammenarbeit bei der entwicklung
neuer militärischer fähigkeiten und
spitzentechnologien erst so richtig
fahrt aufnimmt wir sprechen von massiven
einsatz künstlicher intelligenz
hyperschall raketen.com technologie und
so weiter und so fort mit anderen worten
alles deutet darauf hin dass der
exklusive club das erlesene tandem aus
vertrauen einfluss und macht dass die
vereinigten staaten und das vereinigte
königreich bilden von nun an ein drittes
mitglied haben wird um zu verstehen
warum dieser schritt das potenzial hat
eine neue weltordnung zu definieren
beziehungsweise die bestehende auf ein
ganz neues fundament zu setzen müssen
wir jedoch ein paar wichtige fragen
klären warum ist dieses abkommen so
wichtig und warum ausgerechnet
australien und vielleicht die wichtigste
frage von allen was sind die
auswirkungen auf die wirtschaftlich
wichtigste weltregion dieses
jahrhunderts
[Musik]
der treueste freund
warum ausgerechnet australien nun dafür
gibt es zwei hauptgründe australien das
land des servers der kängurus und des
sydney opera house hat sich in der
vergangenheit als amerikas bester freund
erwiesen vielleicht nicht das stärkste
oder mächtigste freund aber der treuste
von allen down under ist die einzige
nation der welt die an der seite der
vereinigten staaten in allen großen
schlachten der amerikanischen
streitmacht gekämpft hat dazu gehören
beide weltkriege der koreakrieg vietnam
der golfkrieg afghanistan der irak und
sogar der einsatz gegen den islamischen
staat außerdem ist australien eine
reiches und sehr wohlhabendes land das
über reichlich ressourcen verfügt die es
zum beispiel eben auch für die
verteidigung ausgeben kann
[Musik]
im jahr 2009 10 wurde dieses land sogar
zum zweitgrößten waffenimporteur der
welt für knapp hinter saudi arabien und
was glaubst du von dem sie den großteil
der waffen gekauft haben ganz genau 100
us rüstungsindustrie ja die manager von
unternehmen wie lockheed martin cello
dynamics corporation bae systems
raytheon und northrop grumman lassen in
letzter zeit alles stehen und liegen und
holen die bestellformulare raus wenn sie
irgendwo irgend jemanden mit
australischen akzent reden hören und zu
all dem kommt dass australien eben
relativ nah an einer der wichtigsten
geopolitischen zonen der welt liegt mit
anderen worten wenn es um die wahl eines
neuen extrem engen partners geht gibt es
für die usa keine bessere option und
wenn du nur einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte werfen hat washington all
diese tatsachen schon vor jahren erkannt
[Musik]
im jahr 2011 unterzeichneten die beiden
länder ein umfangreiches militärabkommen
das unter anderem die stationierung
einer streitmacht von bis zu 2500
us-soldaten auf australischen
territorium vorsieht und seither sind
die beziehungen immer enger geworden im
jahr 2019 vereinbarte australien mit den
vereinigten staaten in kauf folgen mehr
rüstungsgütern als den gesamten
luftstreitkräften vieler länder
insgesamt zur verfügung stehen 72 f 35
11 18 dollar das sind jetzt zur
elektronischen kampfführung früh an
flugzeuge und c 27 jahren lebt der
transportflugzeuge
darüber hinaus haben beide länder
kürzlich vereinbart die präsenz von us
kampfflugzeugen kriegsschiffe truppen
und boten in australien zu erhöhen mit
anderen worten der treueste freund ist
nun wirklich der treueste freund von
allen und welcher kandidat wäre wohl
besser dafür geeignet dass du einen
großen teil deiner aller modernsten
militärtechnologie mit sind heißt die
antwort ist eindeutig
aber das ist nur der erste der zwei
gründe von denen wir gesprochen haben
man weißt du was der zweite hat sehr
viel mit china zu tun in den letzten
jahrzehnten war australien ein land das
so gute beziehungen zu china und erhielt
das irgend ein hoher chinesischer
beamter in peking wohl irgendwie auf die
idee kam australien fast wie eine
kolonie behandeln zu können und diese
arroganz hat sich im laufe der zeit als
großer fehler erwiesen als sehr großer
fehler dieser fehler war so groß dass
wir darüber bald ein eigenes video
herausbringen werden vergisst also bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren falls
sie es nicht schon getan hast und
aktiviere wird auch das wirklich um
keines unserer spannenden videos mehr zu
verpassen ich danke dir nun aber wieder
zurück nach australien
wie der australische premierminister
scott morrison in boswil berichtete
schickte ihm die chinesische regierung
allen ernstes gar eine liste mit
beschwerden und forderte ihn ganz
unverblümt dass du auf diese schulden
australiens gegen china zu begleichen
wenn er nicht hart bestraft werden solle
was auf dieser liste stand nun seine
kritik am kommunistischen regime in den
worten pekings natürlich hetzkampagnen
gegen china drohungen diebstahl
geistigen eigentums spionage
unterbrechung des tourismus und so
weiter und ja diese reform der
diplomatie ist eine chinesische
spezialität und in internationalen
kreisen als wolf war diplomacy also
wolfs krieger diplomatie bekannt
[Musik]
die diplomaten aus dem reich der mitte
verlassen dass kendra investitionen
chinesischer staatsunternehmen in die
strategische infrastruktur australiens
nicht länger blockieren darf und die
eigenen medien daran hindert geschichten
zu veröffentlichen die das chinesische
regime verärgern könnten ja nur ein paar
höfliche bitten im grunde verlangten sie
von australien dass es seine
souveränität und die meinungsfreiheit im
land aufgibt oder sie zumindest
einschränkt worum ging es peking aber
wirklich nun china bot an das ist eine
beschwerde katalog drastisch reduzieren
werde wenn die australische regierung
von ihrer vehementen forderung nach
einer internationalen untersuchung des
ursprungs des kof zwei die russin china
absehen würde daran liegt also der hund
begraben wickeln versucht jede art von
verdacht es könne am ausbruch von
covidien schuld tragen als
antichinesische hetze zu delegitimieren
tja warum tritt man aber so aggressiv
auf immer noch angeblich nichts zu
verbergen hat wir haben über diese
verwicklungen ja schon in zwei in
unserer videos berichtet und was meint
ihr hat kendra peking geantwortet nun
die antwort als klares nein zu
bezeichnen wäre die untertreibung des
jahrhunderts
die beziehungen der über viele
jahrzehnte engen handelspartner haben
sich durch diese last rose abgekühlt
dass die australische regierung er die
ganze australische gesellschaft china
als aktuell und langfristig größte
potenzielle gefahr des landes einstufen
und vor großen gefahren muss man sich
bekanntlich schützen was lag daher näher
als diesen schutz bei seinen freunden zu
suchen der amerikanische freund und auch
der britische front stand nämlich schon
mit ausgestreckten armen bereit und
boten dem land das die gesamte landmasse
des australischen kontinents ausmacht
allen schutz an denn es brauchen würde
und genau so wurde das trilaterale
militärbündnis autos konzipiert dieses
kürzel besteht übrigens aus den
anfangsbuchstaben der beteiligten
staaten australia united kingdom und
united states gut stellt sich nun die
frage ob dieses neue bündnis dann
wirklich so bedeutend ist und china
wirklich einhalt bieten kann nun ich
denke dass uns diese frage p gegen
selbst bereits beantwortet hat wenn man
sich seine überstunden reaktionen nach
der ankündigung ansieht sollte china
angesichts eines solch emotionalen
australiens nicht mit eiserner faust
vorbereitet sein und ihnen wenn nötig
eine harte lektion erteilen koschine
chefredakteur der staatlichen global
times und nun bleibt noch eine frage zu
beantworten wie genau werden die
langfristigen auswirkungen dieses
bündnis aussehen wie könnte es die
zukunft des asiatisch pazifischen raums
nachhaltig beeinflussen das werden wir
jetzt mal unter die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
lachen und heulen
wir können drei direkt auswirkungen oder
konsequenzen dieser vereinbarung
identifizieren und diese wiederum können
wir auf drei bereiche aufteilen das neue
australien china und frankreich lasst
sie uns doch der einfachheit halber
genau in dieser reihenfolge untersuchen
australien ist ein insel kontinent mit
einer unzugänglichen küste die schwer zu
verteidigen sein könnte in einer zeit in
der kriegsschiffe zunehmend durch
raketenangriffe leicht verwundbar sind
ist es eine allgemein anerkannte
tatsache dass obote mit einer hohen
kapazität eine schlüsselrolle in den
streitkräften der zukunft spielen werden
[Musik]
nun bis jetzt war die vorherrschende
strategien australier als continental
ismus bekannt das ist eine strategie die
sich darauf konzentriert das land vor
direkten militärischen angriffen zu
verteidigen bei dieser strategie braucht
australien wie professor white von der
australian national university betont
keine großen atom u boote sondern viele
kleinere konventioneller u-boote zur
verteidigung seiner küsten eine solche
struktur der streitkräfte sendet allein
schon mangels ausreichender reichweite
eine klare botschaft aus australien ist
nicht daran interessiert an fremden
küsten zu kämpfen doch nun meine lieben
freunde von personalpolitik deutet die
entscheidung für atom u boote auf eine
wichtige verschiebung dieser position
und auch der dahinter liegenden ziele
hin
[Musik]
der große vorteil von atom-u-booten ist
geben dass sie länger unter wasser
bleiben können und mehr platz haben um
mehr waffen und nachschub zu
transportieren außerdem können sie in
der regel mit viel höherer
geschwindigkeit unter wasser navigieren
und in viel größeren tiefen operieren
all das hat einen doppelten vorteil
zum einen können die einsätze besser
geheim gehalten werden und zum anderen
können sie in viel weiterer entfernung
und über einen viel längeren zeitraum
erfolgen mit anderen worten ihre
versionen können weit über die reine
verteidigung der australischen küste
hinausgehen
so wurde beispielsweise geschätzt dass
australiens bestehende konventionelle
u-boote der collins klasse kaum mehr als
elf tage in den gewässern des
südchinesischen meers eingesetzt werden
könnten während die einsatzdauer der
neuen atom u boote viel viel länger ist
dh dass diese neue flotte von
atom-u-booten die bei bedarf auch
tomahawk raketen auf ziele eine land
abfeuern können die us-streitkräfte
problemlos bei überwachungs schutz oder
angriffs missionen unterstützen könnte
und das ist noch nicht alles mit diesem
abkommen senden auch die vereinigten
staaten eine wichtige botschaft aus wenn
ihr angst vor chinas
vergeltungsmaßnahmen habt stehen wir
hinter euch weil es in allem scheint das
alles ein sehr effektiver weg zu sein
vielleicht der effektivste den sie
einschlagen konnten
denn tatsache ist dass heute nur sechs
länder atombetreibern die usa russland
china großbritannien frankreich und
indien australien wird nun das siebte
sein das heißt dass fünfter 7 globalen
atom u boot flotte im konfliktfall gegen
china stehen würden eine recht
ausweglose schachmatt situation die
peking ganz und gar nicht gefällt und
das alles kommt zu einer zeit in der die
chinesische führung sowieso eine harte
zeit durchmacht das nationalistisch
wurde kommunistische oder was er sich
von mir aus auch sozialistische regime
hat durch sein rüdes auftreten streit
mit fast allen seinen nachbarn
losgetreten die popularität des landes
in der internationalen gemeinschaft ist
gesunken unter anderem wegen aktionen
wie der vereinnahmung hongkongs oder der
unterdrückung von minderheiten durch die
vielen lügen und die behinderung taktik
bei den ermittlungsarbeiten in sachen
ursprung des neuen corona virus macht
sich peking auch nicht gerade beliebt
das wirtschaftswachstum hat sich
verlangsamt und zu allem übel droht
bereits das unkontrollierte platzen der
immobilienblase und in all diesen trubel
rollski camping wohl auch noch eine art
kulturrevolution 20 aus bei der die
chinesischen high tech unternehmen
gewaltig unter die räder kommen bei all
diesen sorgen könnte man meinen dass die
machthaber in peking ein wenig
zurückhaltung üben würden um wenigstens
luft schnappen zu können ihr problem ist
jedoch dass sie sich und die
populistische und nationalistisch
aufgepeitschten teile der bevölkerung an
eine bestimmte art des umgangs mit dem
ausland gewöhnt haben wenn sie china
kritisieren oder wenn peking nicht
gefällt was sie tun werden sie bestraft
wie kleine was halle staaten frag
einfach mal südkorea taiwan australien
oder sogar litauen wenn china und die
usa sich streiten ist südkorea das die
schläge abbekommt
litauen beschwert sich über von
sanktionen chinas nach taiwan streit
china verhängt wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen australische unternehmen inmitten
der angespannten beziehungen ebenfalls
australiens ist diese taktik jedoch
gewaltig nach hinten los gegangen und so
wie es aussieht wird sich dieser zu
einem präzedenzfall auswachsen mit einer
für die interessen pekings fatalen
signalwirkung in den rest der welt die
bisherige arroganten nationalistische
art china ist mit schwächeren staaten um
zu sprengen ist damit dem untergang
geweiht
und genau deshalb hat die regierung von
shipping august als eine extrem
unverantwortliche bedrohung bezeichnet
es gab sogar schon öffentliche wut
bekundungen wie diese hier mit nuklearen
boten bewaffnet wird australien selbst
ein ziel für einen möglichen nuklearen
angriff in der zukunft sein wirst du
wirklich ein ziel in einem möglichen
atomkrieg sein oder wirst du frei von
der nuklearen bedrohung sein victoria
ein einflussreicher chinesischer
geopolitische analyst abgesehen von all
der medial verbreiteten boots waren
viele chinesische militär analysten die
sich des riesigen strategischen fehlers
ihrer führung durchaus bewusst waren
jede putin herunterzuspielen
der derzeitige allgemeine trend der
globalen wirtschaftlichen integration
unterscheidet sich stark von der
konfrontation und der spaltung zwischen
den beiden lagern während des kalten
krieges der pakt wird schließlich
australiens kampffähigkeiten verbessern
und den vereinigten staaten helfen ihre
militärische reichweite zu vergrößern
aber er steht keine unmittelbare
bedrohung der
chinesische politik analyst august ist
weit davon entfernt ein abkommen nach
der nato zu sein tatsächlich ist dies
ohnehin nicht gerade das modell welches
die usa in dieser region favorisieren
[Musik]
chinas militärische aufrüstung ist
unbestreitbar in den letzten jahrzehnten
hat das land hunderte von ballistischen
langstreckenraketen entwickelt und
produziert und seine marine ist bereits
die größe der welt gemessen an der zahl
der schüsse seine dominanz in der region
ist jedoch nicht so groß wie man auf den
ersten blick denken könnte so ist die
chinesische marine zwar die mächtigste
in der region aber sie stellt nur etwa
30 prozent der dortigen journal die
anstrengungen von ländern wie südkorea
japan indien taiwan australien oder
vietnam und vielen anderen gleichen die
waagschalen nicht nur aus sondern sie
lassen sie viel weiter zu ungunsten
chinas kippen also wir vielleicht auf
den ersten blick erkennen können vor
allem wenn sie die starke unterstützung
der vereinigten staaten haben wie es bei
australien der fall ist eine
überraschende konsequenz die august
haben könnte ist also gerade die
verringerung der spannungen in der
region denn für diese sorgte in den
letzten jahren vor allem china mit
seiner aggressiven provokation und
expansionspolitik damit könnte nun
schluss sein
[Musik]
aber kommen wir nun zur dritten direkten
folgen des abkommens und zur eingangs
gestellten frage wieso frankreich
dagegen protestiert hat warum war die
kombination so verärgert darüber nun
nicht nur weil sie ins abseits gedrängt
wurde sei dies nicht zu wenn es etwas
gibt das einen franzosen wirklich ärgert
dann ist es wenn man ihn auf der
internationalen bühne schwach aussehen
lässt sondern auch weil sie einen
riesigen rüstungsdeal verloren haben
[Musik]
um die eine vorstellung zu geben autos
hat australien dazu gebracht einen fast
65 milliarden dollar schweren vertrag
mit der französischen militär industrie
über den bau von zwölf konventionellen
barracuda u booten zu kündigen mehr noch
kämmerer hat diesen schritt vollkommen
überraschen vollzogen etwas das der
französische außenminister selbst als
dolchstoß bezeichnete
nun ja manche beobachter haben die
abkürzung frankreichs durch seine nato
partner kritisiert andere haben darin
jedoch nur eine logische konsequenz
gesehen paris das falsche spiel
heimzuzahlen dass es die letzten jahre
selbst mit seinen partnern getrieben
hatte für viele haben london und
washington einfach nur einen günstigen
moment ergriffen um ihre rechnungen mit
der cross zu begleichen die einen für
die arrogante behandlung während des brh
exit die anderen für die
anti-amerikanische färbung von
frankreichs außenpolitik der letzten
jahre und da wäre noch eine sache die
dieser schritt auf jeden fall auch
aufzeigt dass europa immer unwichtiger
wird
denn wieder einmal wird der lauf der
weltgeschichte durch die wichtigsten
globalen akteure maßgeblich in neue
bahnen gelenkt und die eu hat dabei
nichts aber rein gar nichts zu melden so
das sind die wichtigsten punkte und
auswirkungen von august dem
militärabkommen das nicht nur die
vereinigten staaten und das vereinigte
königreich im indopazifik stärkt sondern
auch australien zu einer großmacht
machen wird die neuen boote werden zwar
nicht vor ende des nächsten jahrzehnts
komplett verfügbar sein aber man hat
schon eine überbrückungslösung parat
damit in peking ja kein auge trocken
bleibt
australien erwägt das leasen oder den
kauf bestehen der u boote aus den usa
und großbritannien aber jetzt bist du an
der reihe was denkst du über den august
q wie bewertest du diese strategie der
vereinigten staaten ihre partner im
indopazifik zu stärken was denkst du wie
china darauf reagieren wird bzw
überhaupt reagieren kann wie immer sind
auch eure meinung zu diesem thema schon
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was ja geht uns bitte
einen like teilt ist mit uns freuen denn
vergesst nicht dass awo mit glöckchen
und keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen und unterstützt unsere arbeit
bitte mit einer kleinen spende über den
link in der beschreibung unter diesem
video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]